[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKIT MEHTA: I wanted
to set the context
with what are the
three key things we're
going to talk about.
What is engineering
productivity and what are we
doing to make high-quality
software development easier
and faster?
How do we do this?
By adhering to our guiding
principles of driving test
health, avoiding
performance regressions,
and ensuring
high-quality releases.
And, lastly, bringing
this talk back
to a lot of you who are GCP
developers and consumers,
what are we doing when it comes
to Anthos, which you heard
Sunda talk about and a bunch
of subsequent keynotes,
what we are doing in
terms of engineering
productivity with
respect to Anthos
and how you can
benefit from that.
What can you walk
away from this talk
in terms of tools and
infrastructure we have built,
which you can start using
as soon as you step out
of this room?
So let's get started.
So before we jump
into things, what
do we mean by moving fast
and not breaking things?
Moving fast is good.
It helps you innovate.
It helps you respond to
critical issues and bugs sooner.
It enables better productivity,
because to have a release
chain which keeps
going constantly,
you have to follow the
right engineering practices.
And, lastly, it really makes
sure that code health is
prioritized for that particular
service or, in our case,
the entire platform, because
you cannot move fast if you keep
building technical debt.
But breaking things isn't.
Why is that bad?
It's bad because it
erodes user satisfaction.
Our customers who
use GCP are less
likely to recommend
GCP to other customers
if we constantly break them.
It diminishes the brand.
GCP is used by a bunch
of critical companies
and applications,
and we need to make
sure we have a high
uptime and a high quality.
It makes it hard
for us internally,
as we have seen a few years back
when we started this journey,
to really land our features
and commitments to the roadmaps
we have committed
to our customers.
And, lastly, quality
is table stakes when
it comes to a cloud platform.
When working with
enterprise customers,
quality is table stakes.
So as an enterprise,
you need to move fast.
The expected time for
products has moved from--
shortened dramatically
from years
to days in a lot of cases.
But, again, enterprise
customers want quality.
To Mithra and me, a good
analogy we could think of
was transportation
and high-speed trains.
You want to move fast.
You want to get from
point A to point B
as quickly as possible,
but not while you
risk safety of the passengers.
GCP is a set of
solutions and products
that helps our customers
solve the toughest business
challenges.
We have external
paying customers
who run their applications
at a massive scale on GCP.
Within Google and on GCP,
given its open source model,
we have a lot of developers
contributing to this platform
at all levels of the stack.
These engineers want a
seamless development workflow
and want deterministic signals
through the workflow process.
A quick overview-- what is
engineering productivity?
We started off as a test
engineering organization
which was focused mostly on
the part of the development
workflow after
code gets submitted
and how it gets validated,
deployed, and so on.
About a decade back, we
started pivoting to engineering
productivity, and we started
looking at the entire software
development life
cycle holistically.
We realized it's
important for us
to get involved right
from the design phase
and to also make sure that,
once our features, products,
and services are on production,
they actually are performing,
scaling.
Within Google, we use
this term "landing."
Are they landing?
It's not good enough to launch.
We want to make
sure things land.
As Google started getting
involved in a lot more things,
we started getting involved
with applications within the ML
and AI space, back ends,
front ends, mobile.
And we've been able to take
a lot of the learnings we've
had within Google over
the last two decades
and take the best parts
of it and actually
apply it to GCP and Anthos.
So let's first ground
ourselves in some numbers
to give you all an idea of what
engineering productivity is
and how it fits into
GCP and within Google.
As you can see on
the slide, Google
has about 2 million
lines of code and more--
60k code submissions,
800k builds,
150 million automated tests.
More importantly, all of our
tools are built in-house,
but now we are starting to
build them in open source.
Mithra will go into that.
And they use the same
technologies as Google products
too.
They run in the
same data centers.
A SOA stack handles 2
million QPS, roughly.
So the takeaway from this
slide is it's a massive scale.
So what does EngProd
do as part of this?
Hopefully all of you
recognize what this is.
If you're a GCP customer,
you probably use this.
This is the cloud console.
EngProd works very closely
with the Cloud Console team
to make sure we ship
this twice a week.
Our goal is to establish
biweekly high-quality release
guidance across GCP.
The console is at the
higher part of the stack.
It makes sense to
ship it twice a week.
Our lower-risk storage systems,
code infrastructure systems,
we don't want to ship
them twice a week.
But we do want to ship
them with regular cadence
for the reasons I
explained before.
But we strongly believe
that, internally, we
want to have as frequent
healthy snapshots in most cases,
like daily release
candidates, as we call it.
It gives us the ability to
go faster if we need to.
So how are we ensuring this,
balancing developer velocity
and quality?
We have created a set of guiding
principles that let us balance
developer velocity and quality.
We want to share these
practices and tools with you
all so you can accelerate
at the same pace as we do.
We deliberated on a
philosophy that we just
don't want to be
comfortable catching bugs.
We want to prevent them.
This meant that, in addition
to doing complex qualification
across systems, we
started building tooling
and infrastructure that
enables developers themselves
to qualify their code
before they submit it,
going back to the notion
of preventing things.
This changed the way we
built, qualified, deployed,
and monitored our
applications, again
to balance developer
velocity and quality.
Let's look at what our
guiding principles are.
Our guiding principles
are driving test health,
avoiding performance
regressions,
ensuring high-quality releases.
All of it is anchored in
insightful and actionable
metrics.
Let's take a closer look
into these principles
and see what I'm talking about.
With test health, we aim for
hermetic integration tests,
fast pre-submits, and
elimination of test flakiness.
Internally, we have built
a cloud integration testing
framework that incorporates
these learnings and principles
and enables developers to
write tests once and run them
anywhere.
I'm going to repeat that--
write tests once,
run them anywhere.
That is important because
that has allowed us to really
amplify the value of our tests.
And because the
tests are hermetic,
they are fast, they
don't have flakiness,
and that has really
boosted our ability
to increase the amount
of validation we
can do for a feature,
right from the time
it starts getting
developed to even how it
performs in production.
Under the hood, we have
a bunch of technologies
like resource
pre-provisioning, record replay
to speed up setup and tear down,
which, for those of you who
are in this space, know it
takes up a lot of the time
when it comes to
integration tests.
So let's look at our
next guiding principle--
avoiding performance
regressions.
We want to make performance
a first-class citizen.
We have done that by building
a performance benchmarking
library internally that
service owners and products can
seamlessly integrate
into their products
and get rich
performance benchmarks.
This is now a standard, not only
within GCP but within Google.
This in turn has allowed us
to keep monitoring performance
as a feature or a service
keeps getting developed and not
as an afterthought once
we put it on production
and then figure it out, oh, it
doesn't scale, or it's slow.
Lastly, our third principal--
ensuring high-quality releases.
We wanted to take this
slide as an opportunity
to say that there's a balance
between tooling and process.
As much as effective
tooling is important--
and we have built a bunch of
great tooling in this space--
I think we have learned that
effective process is important
when it comes to
high-quality releases.
We have distilled
the problem on GCP
that if the rate
at which we push
our features from
development to production,
if you're doing that well, we're
ensuring high-quality releases.
We have learned a bunch
of best practices.
We wanted to share a few
of them with you all here.
One of the most important
things we realized
is if you decouple the features
and the binaries, that really
helps your binaries
and your releases
to be a release gain, one
that goes out every day,
every week depending
on the service.
And if there's a certain problem
that shows up in production,
it's mostly guarded
behind a feature flag.
You can just turn off the
flag, and the releases
keep going out.
This also helps
us really install
the engineering discipline we
need for the last bullet here.
If that is a problem introduced
not by a particular feature,
there is some global
state in the architecture,
we have the culture
to figure out
what caused the problem, debug
it, find our exact change,
revert it, cherry-pick the
change that caused the problem,
let the chain keep going,
and go fix it and put it
in the next chain.
This ensures that we
are not taking shortcuts
on critical fixes, critical
P0's, and so on and so forth.
Most importantly, we measure
all of these biometrics.
I read this somewhere
literally half an hour back.
I thought it was good
to share it here.
If you don't know
where you come from,
you don't know where you are.
If you don't know
where you are, you
don't know where you're going.
If you don't know
where you're going,
you're probably going
somewhere wrong.
That brings me to
project health.
We balance developer
velocity and quality
at Google and on GCP via
Project Health, which
we refer to as pH.
We track key metrics across
developer productivity,
release velocity, reliability,
and, most importantly, quality.
We automatically calculate
a project health level, a pH
level, based on
all these metrics.
We have years of data
at Google and within GCP
that the higher a project's
project health level is,
the better they do at balancing
developer velocity and quality.
A higher pH means better
development practices.
A higher pH means a better
ability to fix issues.
A higher pH means you're
following your focus.
You can focus on coding
and not pushing releases
because they are
automatically going
on, and so on and so forth.
Let me ground this with
a concrete example.
Here's an example of a
project health dashboard
for a particular area in GCP.
This is the view that
service area gets, saying
these are all your projects.
Here's your overall
project health level.
This gives them an ability to
zoom into one of these areas
and figure out which
one of these metrics
they are struggling
in and what they need
to devote their resources on.
As engineering
productivity, this is also
very useful information for us.
Because, very often,
there a lot more
developers working on a service
than productivity engineers
working with that service.
So this helps us
prioritize our efforts
and figure out what
are the hot spots
for this particular product
or area and zoom in on that.
So recapping, our
guiding principles
are driving test health,
avoiding performance
regressions, make performance
a first-class citizen, not
an afterthought, ensure
high-quality releases,
both by effective tooling
and process and engineering
discipline, and
measure everything.
I'll invite Mithra
now to talk about what
we are doing along
these principles
when it comes to Anthos,
the tools we have built
and how you all can
benefit from them.
[APPLAUSE]
MITHRA RAJAH: Hi, everyone.
The outside world now uses
VMs, Kubernetes, GitHub,
and containers.
Google software
traditionally used
to be stored in a single
shared repository.
But our landscape is
continuously changing
and we need to evolve to
adapt to this changing
landscape as we are
building tooling for Anthos
and further on.
So let's look at open
source development.
Google works very closely
with Kubernetes and Istio
open source communities
to develop a lot of tools
to improve development
velocity as well as quality.
We contribute very actively
to SIG testing in Kubernetes.
Let us dig a little bit deeper
into the test infrastructure
along the same
guiding principles
that you saw Ankit
talk about just now.
Driving test health.
In the open source
community for Kubernetes,
we helped build the continuous
integration system called Prow.
Prow started in 2016, and we
replaced Jenkins as the system
for Kubernetes.
Why is this important?
Because we no longer need
to run a Jenkins master,
and we can update the service
without any down time.
Another important
thing is that we
test Kubernetes on Kubernetes.
It is very easy to
maintain and deploy
and respond to GitHub webhooks
rather than using a munger.
Testgrid.
So Testgrid provides a
grid of test results,
which gives you very fast
access to test results.
You can also highly
configure this
to look at all the bug
data, and sort through data,
and get like data about grouping
or filing bugs, and so on.
This is integrated
with cloud build.
And so you can go to Results
Store to view all of the cloud
build results and logs and
do more analysis on the data.
Let us see what we
have done in the space
of hermetic infrastructure
when it comes to open source.
Some of you may be familiar
with Kubernetes and Docker.
This is another open source
tool available for use
to you in Kubernetes.
This provides hermetic testing
via a local Kubernetes cluster
that you can run on your
development workstation.
There are no
external dependencies
and it helps you
integration test Kubernetes
applications with other things,
like Istio or Nomos, and so on.
Let's see a quick demo of
how KIND works in action.
I'll give you a
second to absorb this.
Yeah, as you can
see, the cluster
gets created really quickly.
And, basically, it creates
an entire Kubernetes cluster
in a matter of seconds
when you compare that
to a cluster on cloud,
which takes about 4
to 5 minutes to start up.
Avoiding performance
regressions.
We want to make performance a
first-class citizen, like Ankit
was just talking about.
We want to provide
you the ability
to visualize performance data
and catch regressions really
quickly.
And so we are working on
open sourcing tooling that
lets you visualize
performance data
and find these regressions,
just as we do for GCP.
This graph shows the trend
for a performance benchmark.
And you can see that there is
a developer checking in a fix.
And then that caused the
performance regression
to be fixed, and then the
curve came down again.
And this kind of lets developers
collaborate with each other
around performance.
We've already deployed this
to some of our customers
and we are working to
bring this to open source.
Talking about
high-quality releases,
I wanted to highlight how
Jenkins X uses Prow for CI/CD
alongside the Knative
build pipelines.
Let's walk through the
process a little bit.
A developer creates a PR.
GitHub then sends the
PR notification to Prow.
Prow creates a build
on Knative, and it
runs the jenkinsfile
pipeline, and the results
get uploaded resultstore.
So this is one of
the ways that you
can automate your full CI/CD
pipeline using Prow and Jenkins
X on open source.
And let's take a look
at actionable metrics.
Kubernetes was
essentially designed
for software portability and
like developer portability.
To kind of ensure
consistency and portability
when we move across cloud
providers and cloud,
we worked with Kubernetes
for the CNCF, which
is Cloud Native Compute
Foundation, as you might know,
and helped design or implement
the conformance program.
This infrastructure lets you
measure the end-to-end coverage
when it comes to Kubernetes
APIs and visualize the results
of coverage over time.
This is all integrated
into Testgrid,
so you can view the coverage
numbers for Kubernetes APIs.
We've also enabled
this for Knative.
And so, here, you can see
a graph that shows you
how the coverage
numbers trend over time,
and you can see the
results on Testgrid.
And then, moving on to a
hybrid cloud model with Anthos.
We wanted to make sure that,
as the landscape evolves
to support hybrid
cloud and multi-cloud,
we used the same CI/CD and
tooling processes to also test
a hybrid cloud platform.
So we make use of the
same CI and CD systems
with Prow,
resultstore, and so on
and make sure that we can also
test on-prem the same way we
test on GCP.
Let's take a little
bit of a closer
look at the qualification
pipeline for Anthos.
So a developer has
code in his repository,
and this is the
system under test.
So we want to make
sure that you are
testing your pre-submit flows
and submitting the code.
When code gets submitted,
a git checkout happens,
and we run an on-prem cluster
of Prow on a vSphere lab.
And then this creates a GKE
cluster, runs all the tests,
and then publishes the
test results to Testgrid.
Once the developer
submits the code,
we also run tests
on post-submit.
Certain tests are
run pre-submit,
and some on post-submit.
And you can basically see
how Prow again runs the tests
and publishes the
results to Testgrid.
So this helps us really
easily interpret the CI signal
towards release readiness.
So to summarize again,
engineering productivity
makes quality software
development easier and faster.
And we do this by
adhering to our guiding
principles of
driving test health,
avoiding performance
regression, and ensuring
high-quality releases.
And you saw a little bit about
Anthos engineering productivity
tools and how a lot of them
are available for your use
and benefit.
[MUSIC PLAYING]